you know 25 years ago it was sufficient
to know how to balance your checkbook or
how to manage a savings account but
today Americans are having to navigate
through an increasingly sophisticated
products and services so you think about
it in your own life today I mean think
about even you know the credit cards
that you have to choose from you know
ATM card debit card or how about if you
want to buy a car you know do you lease
it do you buy it outright or do you get
a loan you know what's the best what's
the best thing for you or even you know
the world of investing you want to save
for your child's education you have a
choice of a custodian account and
education savings account or a 529 plan
or how about your own retirement you
know do you open up you know after your
401k do you open up a Roth IRA or a
traditional IRA you know or what what
mutual funds are investments do you
choose from I mean there's six you know
thousands and thousands of mutual funds
to choose from you know not to mention
the newly created exchange-traded funds
or hedge funds so you know you put this
all together and you think about you
know if it's complicated for us you know
college educated people or but think
about the young high school kid or
college graduate who has never had asks
access to financial education at all may
feel so you put this all together and
the the harsh reality is is that
Americans from all walks of life are not
equipped to make sound financial
decisions our financial system is so
complex today yet schools aren't
teaching our kids there are only three
states in this country that require
personal finance as a graduation
requirement and parents aren't talking
to their kids about money management in
fact fewer than one in three families
have frequent conversations about money
and investing and we know from our
studies that teens put learning how to
manage money as one of their top
priorities and
act eighty-nine percent of teens say
that learning how to invest and make
their money grow is a top priority so
there's a huge opportunity for this
country for school systems for parents
to teach our kids and involve our kids
in the day-to-day household management
of money and we can change this whole
you know lack of financial nursing this
country if we all get involved
you